Sony's standalone Venom movie has come and
gone, and we all survived.
Now let's eat some lobsters and try to explain
the end of Venom.
Major spoilers ahead.
Switching sides
By the movie's climax, the goopy alien Venom
tells Eddie Brock that he's ready to help
humanity repel his race's invasion of Earth.
Why?
According to the alien, it's because on his
home planet, he's kind of a loser, just like
Brock.
It's a great line, but it doesn't really explain
the pivotal moment.
However, it could have some roots in the comics.
In Venom: First Host #1, we learn that the
symbiote that would eventually become Venom
was cast out from the rest of its gloopy brothers
and sisters, possibly the result of some kind
of "cognitive damage."
As a result, Venom's never really been quite
like the rest of the Marvel Comics symbiotes
we've met.
Of course, none of that sounds as good as
Venom calling himself a loser, so it didn't
make it into the script.
Alien Nation
Life Foundation head honcho Carlton Drake
was up to his armpits in symbiotes for most
of the movie, but by the end, only Riot and
Venom remained.
So, you may be wondering: what happened to
the rest?
Well apparently the symbiotes couldn't live
in their given hosts and died...which kind
of makes Riot's plan to steal a rocket and
bring a whole bunch more anaerobic symbiotes
to an oxygen-rich planet filled with incompatible
hosts kind of...dumb.
"You suck."
But enough about all that!
Did you see the part where Venom chomped on
some guy's head?
That was great.
That red-haired Bozo?
So what's the deal with Woody Harrelson and
that bright red wig during the first post-credits
scene?
Well that, dear friends, was Cletus Kasady,
a mass murderer who eventually becomes the
supervillain named Carnage.
Carnage is yet another symbiote, an even goopier,
evil-er offspring of the Venom lifeform.
That's right, y'all: Venom's gonna be a mom.
Despite the fact that all the other symbiotes
died in this movie, we know that if Sony decides
to greenlight a Venom sequel, we've just met
the lead villain.
A lethal protector?
Venom had a pretty hard time keeping his violent
urges in check for the majority of the film.
"So many snacks, so little time"
The bodega scene at the end is a clear example
of that, since Mrs. Chen sees Eddie's transformation
and head-eating habits.
So is Eddie going public with his alter ego,
Venom?
The short answer is, well, maybe!
We know from the comics, especially the "Lethal
Protector" story from the 1990s, that Brock's
identity as Venom was known to the residents
of San Francisco though, more as an unstable
monster than a lovable creep.
The end of the movie seemed to indicate that
the film franchise may be going this route
as well, at least as far as folks in his San
Francisco neighborhood are concerned.
MCU later?
So is Venom in the MCU?
Sure, Sony and Marvel Studios agreed to share
Spidey for a few MCU movies.
But Spider-Man's supporting characters remain
a continuity mystery, since Sony owns their
movie rights and Marvel doesn't.
There's really no clear answer to this, even
by the movie's end.
No one mentions Tony Stark or SHIELD, so Venom's
connections to the wider Marvel Universe are
thin to non-existent.
But no one mentions Spider-Man, either.
In the end, Venom seems to take place in its
own little dimension, so all you superfans
hoping to see Doctor Strange team up with
Venom are probably out of luck.
Unless…
Into the Spider-Verse
Venom's second post-credits scene teased the
animated Spider-Man: Into the Spider-Verse,
which teams-up different versions of Spider-Man
from across the multiverse.
And the comics it's based on had more than
just comic book Spideys, including guys like
the Spider-Man from the 1970s Japanese TV
show, at least a couple cartoon Spider-Men,
and even the Spider-Man from Capcom's fighting
games.
There was a Spider-Man for every fan.
So what's this got to do with Venom?
Well, the Spideys from Sony's previous two
Spider-Man movie franchises Tobey Maguire
and Andrew Garfield can theoretically connect
up with Tom Holland's Spider-Man.
And while Spider-Man didn't show up in this
movie, Into the Spider-Verse still connects
all of them to Venom.
Venom may never share a milkshake with Drax
the Destroyer, but you can rest easy knowing
that somewhere in the far reaches of the Spider-Verse,
it just might happen.